on savait que les changements
climatiques frappait plus fort dans
l'hémisphère nord de la planète que dans
le sud
mais les chiffres d'une nouvelle étude
canadienne sur le climat donne presque
froid dans le dos depuis 1948 la
température annuelle moyenne sur terre
augmenté de 0,8 degrés au canada c'est
le double et dans le grand nord presque
le triple qu'on a un rapport aujourd'hui
qui démontre le canada se réchauffe deux
fois plus vite que le reste du monde
ça veut dire plus de bien des deux
ambeyrac tueur extrêmes nous devons
prendre l'action en tête de liste des
préoccupations l'impact que le climat
aura sur les populations humaines dans
les régions arctiques où la fonte des
glaces a un effet radical sur
l'environnement l'article est en train
de nous montrer un peu ce qu'ils sont ce
que l'avenir nous réserve si on ne fait
rien parce que le réchauffement est déjà
très important et c'est ce qui pourrait
arriver sur la planète si on prend pas
les choses en main le rapport indique
également que toutes les provinces et
toutes les régions sont susceptibles
d'être frappés par cette hausse des
températures c'est clair qu'il ya un
coût à l'inaction sur les changements
climatiques donc plus importante l'aller
les changements de température
plus il y aura des impacts plus faudra
s'adapter plus faudra aussi faire face à
des situations extrêmes
un bon indice du choc qui nous attend le
nombre de journées très chaudes que
subiront les grandes villes avant l'an
2000 on recensait moins d'une dizaine de
journées caniculaires par année à
montréal une quinzaine à toronto
si à peine 20 ans ce chiffre va tripler
cela dit il même s'il est extrême le cas
du canada est évidemment relié à celui
du reste de la planète
pourquoi pas les seuls se verse à l'inde
la chaîne des états unis tous les pays
vont avoir à faire face à cette réalité
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
besoin d'agir ensemble mais on pourrait
pas s'en d'échapper en se disant que ben
écoutez nous on n'aurait pas grand
impact pour d'autres le fassent je pense
à votre effort mondial tous les pays
nordiques connaît ce phénomène de hausse
rapide de température causé entre autres
par l'accumulation de chaleur au sol à
mesure que la calotte glaciaire
disparaît ici normaux grondin radio
canada montréal